it was all very methodical
you know it was like i want to create
but then like well what how do i get
there
if you had gotten into tv directing
right out of sundance
do you think you'd still be directing
today
no i don't i think if i got into
television directing right out of
sundance
uh
i would have made
too many mistakes to build a career
i think that
the the first thing being tv and film
are two different
um they're two different mediums clearly
but
making a film
whether you subscribe to the artur
theory or not like it's the director's
medium
and
television is the writer's medium and
if you don't understand that
you're not going to fare well
and i think that
over the 17 years that we've you know
identified between sundance and first
job
you know
i did a lot of branded content i did
some commercial work where i learned
that
the product
it's the products medium
you know what i mean it's the it's the
agencies medium and the brands medium
and learning that was something that i
could take to television and understand
like i'm gonna have ideas here i'm gonna
have pitches or interpretations of
a scene or a script that
may not align with what the show runner
wants and that's fine you know i won't
like go into my shell and say well i'm
not offering any more ideas because you
don't like them
uh i know that there are things that i'm
not aware of because
i'm seeing episode 208
and you know that this is going to end
in season 5 in a particular way and that
great idea i have doesn't complement
what you're doing you know
so
the understanding that reality and how
to finesse um
the relationships that the relationship
dynamics that come with that
um
you know having the skill to deal with a
variety of different types of
personalities on on a set cast crew
executives
um
and
having
the stamina
and or
work
ethic and work structure
to
deal with the realities of television
production which is
driven by how fast can you do everything
you know to some degree i wouldn't have
been i would not have been
prepared for that
so then even though the wait was long
and here you are
essentially helping other people's
dreams at the school nothing wrong with
that but
maybe it had seasoned you in the right
way definitely seasoned me you know i
i'm definitely not campaigning for you
know 17 years um
before like uh you get hired to direct
but i i do think that there's
you know
there's
are things to learn before you can
really
excel in particular professional
environments you know if you you didn't
ask me this but like if if i had to
identify it i'd say around based off of
the experiences that i had i'd say
around
2008 i was probably ready to do tv i
learned enough
about like
people in politics
you know what i mean and and being a
filmmaker and delivering for a client i
learned enough i think by that time that
i i wouldn't have been you know
perfect but i would have i wouldn't have
stunk up the place and i would have been
able to get in there and kind of figure
it out um
and avoid
big mistakes
well you'd been through 9 11 and then
then the recession was around that time
so it brought out probably
interesting sides to people
in stress like that
um
so
once you've kind of weathered stuff like
that you think you were just like okay
some pretty bad stuff has happened in
the world
and i think i know where my footing is
you know because
if you're steering a ship i.e a set that
there's drama on not enough time
somebody's mad or whatever
um you know what's the worst that could
happen right right
so so was there were there certain
divine i i don't mean to assume that i
know what happened i apologize were
there certain things that happened that
just got you ready for it or was just
time of you know the work i think it's
just time you know like you do
you do so many projects and
murphy's law
anything that can go wrong will go wrong
it's going to happen on every project so
then it's like
do you have the thing you did and you're
like oh that little thing i thought that
was just going to be a weekend that was
the project that i had a fire on set you
know fires happen okay or um that was
the project where i had
you know uh
a super egotistical person who wouldn't
come out of their trailer for x amount
of time okay dealt with that um you know
what i mean like uh and i had to be the
one to get him out
this was the one where they
pulled out the money at the last minute
and i had so you just kind of you get
you begin to get
enough of a window into
you might as well just be open to the
world exploding you know it's like it's
like oh
pandemic right okay you know like and
not not minimizing it but like you're
you do like get to a point you're like
i don't know what to what the day will
bring but i know that i'll be
able to
absorb it
you know
um
appreciate the moment and try and find a
way to
get us home you know with
some semblance of what we
set out to accomplish today
and once you kind of get that
you can kind of
you know
go with the flow
whereas maybe being slightly younger and
maybe different things it would rattle
you too much oh you'd be
extremely rattled and
there'd be
you know self-loathing and
self-importance and why me and it's like
that doesn't that doesn't get
the thing shot
sure it's fun to wallow in though it's
fine it is i mean that that's that's
what going home is for you know you go
home and then you tell your partner and
like can you can you believe what
happened today and they're like i'm uh i
guess i have to hear this for 30 minutes
but you know
that's how it goes
what was the point of no return for you
not when you were inspired to be a
director but when you realize that you
could actually make a living doing this
so
well i realized that being a feature
filmmaker was not going to be a way to
make a living
the moment that i
said that's a wrap on my first feature
because you know it was
the money was raised over uh
it was the script was written and the
money was raised over a six-year period
and the amount of money i paid myself
and the other producers you know were
all paid equally
was not even
like
i barely have to file taxes for the
money you know what i mean like it was
very low
and
so
i'm like alright well that was six years
you know that was fifteen thousand
dollars over six years all right well
that's not gonna you know translate to
moving out of my mother's house and
whatever so um
while i had a part i had a full-time job
at nyu but that was you know
35 000 a year it wasn't much living in
new york new jersey and so
um i said well what do i know
that
how can i take this skill that i think i
have um and find a way to
exploit it you know for myself and make
money off of it and that was when i
started
building the production company to make
videos
um
and
you know
that was a journey of
um taking on more it was it was a pivot
moment like we've kind of talked about
it's like well
these budgets are
small in their own way you know but
maybe if i wear more hats then i can
keep more of the money
because the first couple projects that i
did it was like well
the editor is making more than almost
anyone because they're sitting here
for the longest amount of time like like
really on the clock like four or five
days of editing um while you know
i'm shooting for one day producers
producing you know forever alone but
they were becoming the ones who were
making the most money so i was like well
if i edit then i'll make more money if i
shoot it then i'll make more money if i
produce it and maybe bring on an
assistant
i'll make more money and so
um i was constantly trying to figure out
how to survive economically as a
filmmaker
but that was you know very shortly after
i finished the first feature um
over time you know as
the company grew and was doing all right
with those videos
i look at it and i say well how can i
make more money
so i was like we should be doing
campaigns for people
because this one-off video thing is i'm
looking at my quickbooks at the time and
i'm like well all these budgets are in
the same strike zone i feel like the
only way to
get more money is to change the cache of
hiring us which i don't think is going
to happen without a big project
or we offer
more services and charge more because of
the volume of it and
you know the irony of it is that that
decision
to go toward campaigns led to
um some of the best performing years for
us
and it was one campaign in particular
where i was like i'm going to take my
fee and make a short film
because by that time it's 2014
i'm so far removed in my mind from
something that i've directed for myself
because
the feature film premium i directed in
o5 it finished its kind of distribution
trajectory by o7
i directed a feature documentary in 0708
and so now i'm six years past when i
could look at like
version of what i could do as a
narrative director
while having done thousands of videos
for clients and i was like well let me
make something for me
and uh this short film that i made you
know
was the thing that got picked up by hbo
and got me into director programs and
led to
tv directing and still is a sample that
i use now
um wow
like
six seven years later um because it was
just it's a pretty unique execution and
concept so
you know um
i kind of was always i always had my
mind and my target on how to
turn this into a career
without it having to be reliant upon
the
models that everyone
believes are the only options
and so you were no longer working at nyu
or just part-time i was so i i was
working full-time at the desk job until
2012.
and honestly that was the year of my
10-year
10-year anniversary at the job and i was
like
i'm not gonna get no disrespect to the
job it was great but personally i was
like i'm not gonna get y'all gave me a
certificate for 10 years you're not
going to give me a watch for 25. like
i'm not doing it so
um
i left that in the 10th year
i quit
but uh
i was
teaching at that time
and i was like all right well the
teaching is
not as much of a guarantee
but it gives me more free time and i
think that i can balance
i can use that free time to devote
toward building the production company
then i can teach to have that kind of
smaller guaranteed income
um
and then you know
hopefully be able to push toward the
other you know my pers my passion
projects at the same time so i mean i
feel like what's interesting is i hear
myself talk or it may not be interesting
but
it was all very methodical
you know it was like i want to create
but then like well what how do i get
there i'm not just going to sit here and
like
look at the stars and you know daydream
about how great it would be to like make
this thing it's like what can i
literally wake up and do tomorrow to
move
the needle toward
you know
this goal
so if you hadn't started that production
company then you may never have taken
some of that money and put it into the
short that
yeah i wouldn't have had i wouldn't have
had 30 000 to do it right wow you know